Seguimos con nuestra sección directo a
nos vamos hasta la capital de Perú a
Lima de la mano de nuestro corresponsal
Francisco Zacarías con quién vamos a
ahondar en la nueva polémica que salpica
a las figuras del Estado peruano Es que
la fiscal general de Perú Patricia
Benavides figuró temporalmente como
fallecida en el Registro Nacional de
identificación y estado civil el
Ministerio Público ya anunció que
procederá con las acciones legales
correspondientes Francisco qué ha
sucedido para que se haya desatado este
nuevo escándalo Parece que la fiscal
general y el presidente Pedro Castillo
aparecían en la lista de supuestos
fallecidos
Buenas noches Rodrigo todo comenzó
cuando medios locales denunciaron que
Alejandro Sánchez figuraba como
fallecido en el Registro Nacional de
defunciones que maneja el reniec Pero
quién es Sánchez él es un prófugo de la
justicia y también dueño de una vivienda
donde el presidente Pedro Castillo
realizaba reuniones clandestinas con
algunos empresarios según el reniec la
muerte de Sánchez habría producido el 25
el 11 de octubre fecha cuando la
justicia peruana ordenó una serie de
allanamientos y capturas a personas
vinculadas al presidente Pedro Castillo
este caso no es el único en la fiscal
general de Perú y el presidente de
Castillo también figuran Dentro de este
registro de defunciones y tal como lo
señala este registro el 25 de septiembre
Pedro Castillo habría muerto decapitado
en el Palacio de Gobierno alrededor de
las 18 horas tratando de apagar este
escándalo
anunció que todo esto se debería por
documentación falsa que habría entregado
el Ministerio de salud a ese organismo
ahora después el Ministerio de salud
rechazó las acusaciones y señaló que el
único responsable de todo esto es reniec
porque maneja el Sistema Nacional de
defunciones estas explicaciones no han
convencido al parlamento y señalan que
todo se trataría de una estrategia del
gobierno del presidente Pedro Castillo
para que los Implicados En las
investigaciones puedan evadir a la
justicia y Francisco que están haciendo
por tanto ahora las autoridades para
resolver esta situación
Bueno le cuento que Fiscales
especializados en ciberdelincuencia
están interviniendo las instalaciones
del Ministerio de salud así como de
reniec Por otra parte la defensoría del
pueblo han intervenido El Sistema
Nacional de defunciones y por su parte
el congreso está citando tanto al
ministro de salud como a la jefa del
organismo de reniec para que se pueda
esclarecer este caso de otro lado hay a
esta hora trabajadores del organismo
público reniec que están exigiendo la
renuncia de la jefa de esta institución
Mientras tanto reniega ha anunciado que
va a dejar de emitir certificados de
defunciones
Francisco Zacarías Muchas gracias